today we're going to talk about setting
up a plate for qpcr for a well plate the
first thing you're going to want to do
is you're going to want to make some
master mix each vendor has a master mix
formula you'll want to follow this
usually comes as a packaged insert each
master mix has primer probe water enzyme
and your dntp buffer mix the primers are
used to find the target sequence the
probes are used for visualization of the
target the enzyme is used for
replicating the target sequences lastly
the dntps are the building blocks for
amplifying nucleic acids make sure to
keep all ingredients on ice also to make
sure to keep your final master mix on
ice make sure you keep your master mix
plate on ice just keep everything on ice
it's smart to plate the master mix first
into your plate the reason you want to
do this is because you're less concerned
about sample contamination at this point
you can also reuse pipette tips if you
want to save some money after the master
mix is in the plate you can add your
sample do not reuse tips at this point
make sure you use filter tips do not
forget to leave some spots on your plate
for your positive and negative controls
when everything is mixed you want to
properly seal your plate make sure to
use the correct optical seals if you're
doing qpcr you can use this scraper to
seal your plate
[Music]
if you want to get a very good seal you
want to make sure you do a crisscross
pattern on the wells
when everything is sealed make sure to
spin down your plate around 3000 rpms
for a minute and it's ready to go if you
found that this type of content was
really helpful for you please like and
subscribe so we know to keep making more
bye